[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
june 18th pikes peak center colorado
springs colorado prepares
for the funniest
show
[Music]
[Applause]
that's good i'm feeling it
i'm gonna take this one
because i'm free
yeah
yep
yep oh he's still there joe lewis is
good
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
that's called second time better be the
charm uh started those who were watching
on on mug club we had to redo the intro
we're on we're good tool man right yes
youtube we apologize about that there
was some kind of an issue with the
streaming uh glad to be with you monday
look we have let's talk about today i
went to go see the jurassic kingdom
jurassic world
i don't know the name jurassic world old
dominion fallen kingdom
so that you don't have to
uh
this is what we call foreshadowing i
don't know if you can guess what the
review is going to be but i'm
foreshadowing like you know someone who
writes fiction
call me steinbeck and uh we have other
we have other things to talk about today
i don't even know this but some um some
feds i mean white supremacists were
caught in idaho for uh
uh planning to riot intent to riot dear
which is interesting yeah because it's
not a thing and
canada my home country this is important
for you to note the prime minister of
canada uh
just went on he he is now saying what
we've been saying on the show for a long
time saying you don't have the right to
firearms for self-defense in canada you
don't have the right because we don't
have a constitution you do not have the
right to defend yourself with firearms
in canada and we don't want that and
it's important for you to understand
this because canada is just a skip and a
hop away i grew up right i was 45
minutes from the upstate new york border
you just
you cross a border and you are in a land
where you don't have the right to speak
freely and you don't have the right to
defend yourself and that is what they
want if you look at the case law here in
the united states it's not about the
grip it's not about the trigger it's not
about the bump stock it is do you have
the right to own a firearm everywhere
else in the world says no this is the
one place where we say yes why
because it is at least as it's
interpreted right now
absolute so my questions to you do you
believe the second amendment is absolute
i want you to comment below it's an
important question i'm curious to see
what you have to say if there are
exceptions also did you see jurassic
kingdom jurassic world whatever the
title is did you see it and did you also
think that it was a festering pile of
dog feces uh okay
and we have michael moore on the show i
forgot he reached out we're talking
about the second amendment reaching
across the aisle we will have him on the
show so look
everyone in chat be respectful i
appreciate that he's coming on the show
disagree with him of course but he's
from our hometown of michigan yes gerald
a is here you doing well town of
michigan i'm doing well good and uh dave
landau quickest man on his feet how are
you ahoy good i didn't watch that movie
good for you my son did right that's why
i didn't ask him how he's doing i don't
care after making me watch that movie
which brings us right into let's just
get this over with just rip off
rip off the tyrannosaurus rex size
band-aid
it's time for a mug club movie review
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so jurassic world fallen
kingdom dominion
fallen kingdom was the last one i think
it was the last one yeah so now the
fallen kingdom is being dominated i
don't know what's got a dominion well
before i get uh okay let me show you the
machine let me just let you know let me
preface it with this uh as far as the
rating okay so you don't waste your time
if you don't want to watch the rest of
this uh two mugs down absolutely it's
not even close
that is one big pilot
good good work in it yeah
yeah and the movie is so there are so
many reasons to dislike it apparently i
was snoring because it's like three
hours long it is long yeah uh
first before i address it let's show a
clip so you know the kind of festering
fecal matter that we're dealing with
oh yes this is where bryce dallas howard
outruns a velociraptor
dead she's already dead
she's already dead 15 times she's dead
[Music]
and that cgi would look bad for a video
game
oh my god it's like you're watching so
she made it and the dinosaur barely made
it barely made it yeah yes i get mad
when i wa and i know it's not supposed
to be realistic but there is a certain
point look i get mad when people outrun
the dog in a film more than four paces
of course you could start with joe lewis
at the beginning of this hallway you
wouldn't make it past the studio door
before he would be in front of you
lunging upon you right is this made from
stock footage of the da vinci code by
the way where are they
tom hanks in a mullet all right some
guy's flogging himself i like how one
scene the velociraptor is like right
next to her and the next one she's put
some distance on him i'm like oh so she
could run 70 miles an hour because he
can only run 60. well because there's
one big advertisement for women's sports
yeah
the dinosaurs like male dinosaurs like i
want to play too yeah i can just a
velociraptor going on a wnba court sees
all the weaves and tampons
my son saw it i i he went with a group
of friends and he's like daddy uh the
guy chokes out a dinosaur he goes you
can't choke out a diamond
it was seven i should let you know
spoiler alert this is when the source is
going
and then all of a sudden chris it's
about to spit the venom and chris pratt
just comes like ew you stop
like a muppet king
yeah and my son whose seventh season
just goes
[ __ ]
he's willing to take a lot but not that
and
before we go on to the rest of the film
look here's the thing too with these big
budget pictures we actually have an
exclusive here oh okay they often take
multiple endings if you've watched dvds
blu-rays you know they'll take multiple
endings especially with these cinematic
universes and actually at the end of the
previous film fallen kingdom a lot of
people don't know this uh there was a
version where instead of you know
hitting the button and allowing the
dinosaurs to go out and kill all of the
neighbors um
they didn't hit the button and the
dinosaurs were kept in the building that
burned down so obviously they didn't
make it and we actually we had the
script rights
we did here blah blah blah we produced
films where the script writes to
the sequel to jurassic uh uh world
fallen kingdom but we had the rights to
the third film
with that alternate ending we have a
clip
you know
this is nice
[Music]
you know it's a role it's like it's a
roll of the dice whenever you're buying
script rights and we should have like
the rights to the other versions just i
don't know though it's pretty good it
was better than it was much better
better than jurassic
world two i know it's so hard jurassic
world fallen kingdom dominion jeff
goldblum was a parody of himself let me
tell you why it was terrible okay the
story is obviously laughable but you're
not going for a story uh it's uh the
acting is shockingly bad now i like
chris pratt and so i'm i know people
give me crap for this
it's just this is possibly the worst
big budget film yeah that i've
ever seen the cgi would be bad for a
video game uh it's it's to the point of
not just being unrealistic of course
we're dealing with dinosaurs but yeah
they're not even realistic by their own
standards the scale of the dinosaurs
change um i mean the messaging is
terrible they use now this in there as a
source or like which you know if you
know what that is a far left news source
yeah it starts with jeff goldblum
showing velociraptors apartments right
yes ah get your apartment at
apartments.com yeah that's nice right
here in rome yeah rent will uh uh find a
way
and he's a parody of himself and then
the messaging that they try and push of
course about climate and this is before
by the way they wanted to tell everyone
that the vaccines are great because they
were dealing with a biotech company a
pharmaceutical company which were evil
because they wanted them to be like
monsanto but then you realize there are
a lot of parallels to pfizer
and then at the end
spoiler alert at the end they show
elephants
running with triceratops elephants can't
run with hippopotamuses right and then
they show a leviathan with a humpback
whale
it's lunch they can't live with sharks
and what was it they have the other ones
with these horses yeah the iguanodons
the iguanodons with the horses that's
another one where again a seven-year-old
said yeah he's riding a horse and he
lasso is a dinosaur and i was like yeah
this just sounds awesome
that's like three times the size of the
horse right that's what he said the
dinosaur would look back and be like huh
whatever and you know what here's the
thing i don't know why you know they
make this big deal she's trying to
outrun the raptor because you find out
that it's so easy even a child can do it
you can just stop a velociraptor even
though it's you know the size of a human
with the brain of a bird by doing this
hey
listen to me eyes here ice here and the
raptor's like
oh
i don't know what to do it's like what
you do with a grizzly bear right yeah
same difference right yeah i wanted to
play dead
no it's terrible too they tried to throw
in like every possible storyline that
they could find right develop any of
them and then this is i guess this is
what pisses me off like the trx is lost
a couple of times but they always let
the t-rex win in the end like it looks
t-rex wins in the end right
they end it with a c like how is this
going to possibly end i don't know the
t-rex fighting somebody looking like
he's gonna lose yeah and then finding a
way to win only because he has help yeah
it's the equivalent of like hulk hogan
when he's getting beaten like yeah
and then he comes back and he beats them
and somebody comes in from the audience
and clotheslines the guy that's on him
that's what it's like it's like the the
fish ate the other dinosaur last time
and then this time he gets his butt
kicked and then another one comes in it
looks like some weird edward
scissorhands bird and you didn't like
these and you like you love crap i it's
easy
yeah i i have a low bar with movies i
like to i like story lines i can kind of
fill in the holes myself but this chris
pratt looked like he was phoning it in
like if you watched his face during
scenes where he wasn't talking he looked
ashamed of himself he really did it
just flogging himself
oh our daughter's back
yeah well look if you thought hey you
know what jurassic park needs is uh it
needs a villain who shows up like
halfway through and no one cares about
and it needs uh clones
then this is the film for you yeah if
you said that's what jurassic park needs
and uh we also need to care about people
more than the dinosaurs when really you
just want to see them get eaten it was
just also when i was there i know people
say i'm being a snob and this is no look
i like plenty of large-scale films okay
i loved top gun we talked about it the
issue here too i went every single
preview was for a reboot for a sequel or
kung fu panda that wasn't kung fu panda
it was like samurai tiger
it's kung fu panda but with a tiger look
people say this is what people want it's
not what people want these are films
that are being made so that they can be
marketable in china and you know what if
they actually offered you some mid-level
thrillers think about the great ones
that we have like fatal attraction like
basic instinct like a move a movie like
breakdown or look like look down is
brilliant it's fantastic or even once
upon a time in hollywood there just
aren't enough of those being made
because it's either ultra low budget
right super indie mumble core crap or
they want to create a universe so that
they can license it for merchandising
the truth is hollywood is not actually
responding to what the market would want
they're trying to cater to these
international markets and just say
what's the easiest way to throw this
down center plate there is nothing
original about this film there is
nothing redeeming about this film it's
also not even entertaining if it was
just crap but at least it was fun to
watch i wanted everyone to go extinct
can i can i play two mugs down again
wait one more yeah that's fine i think
it's fair
[Laughter]
i wish
it was gene
yeah maybe these writers should take a
cue from the t-rex and shorten the
length
yeah two and a half hours well that's
crap amazing is the human intention span
for one of those is 90 minutes really
right and now when people are now dumber
and have a shorter attention span
they're like what should we do make it
three hours yeah yeah on top of 36
minutes of previews none of which i
wanted to see no i'm not kidding the
movie didn't i saw it at 7 25 it didn't
start until after eight i looked at my
watch and your son was seven seven yeah
i remember the first two films that i've
recognized were terrible when i was like
oh they can spend a lot of money to make
crap the pest with john leguizamo and
batman and robin
awful in every way as a child i realize
this is really bad and i feel
i feel as though they're pandering i
feel they don't respect my
seven-year-old intelligence no it's very
offensive that you just have bane
covered in crazy straws it's a wrestler
he doesn't even talk yeah
the point is we locked people down right
they couldn't go to theaters for years
we have a mental health crisis and then
you thrust in front of them this crap
hollywood we've got to do better i you
know other uh
you don't want this to get worse you
have a mental health crisis and part of
me wish that i was watching this in
aurora colorado this has been a monthly
movie review
[Applause]
that's how you know it's bad if amy
schumer being in it would have improved
it oh it would have made it way better
she doesn't make anything better the fat
bitchiosaurus
no i think finds a way honestly i gotta
say it sounds like every movie she's
made is better than that yeah well
that's true i would rather i would
rather be clockwork orange in front of i
feel pretty yes
all right
moving on here to another uh another
story uh patriot front which is a white
supremacist group yeah of course of
non-federal agents by the way worst
white supremacist group ever they're
really they haven't done anything with
jews with blacks never even heard of
them no well i mean i think i've heard
of them like maybe once
maybe i don't know
i can't do the jokes they're a sponsor
oh i've heard of the supply yes
entirely different totally different
they're delicious it's a joke yes it's a
joke a joke uh patriot front not
delicious
one dare we say unsavory no i would say
the opposite they're putting sucks yeah
i bet they're all bad ranchers as well
yeah i guarantee ranchers
when i see them i want to use my walter
and i want to manscape them with my car
they're not very clear about what they
want
and bankrupt thank you yeah
so
the lights just shut off
[Laughter]
i had to lose all the sponsors
so uh patriot front uh there was an area
federal agent among them and we know
that because we'll never know that um
this is on saturday uh some of their
members were arrested uh in idaho and
i'll explain to you why but i think we
have a clip
you know what they're going to have in
their pocket
[Music]
what is that dark man
yeah
it's the modern day clan
[Music]
now let me be clear about a couple of
things here um we don't have all the
information a lot of people obviously
naturally suspecting that there could be
federal agents in there why well because
the federal agents plotted to kidnap
governor whitmer and of course this was
a this was a sham it was a sham trial
where basically okay they couldn't
charge anybody and for some reason the
fed's got away with it this has happened
many many times so it's right to it is
correct for you to be suspicious but i
can't say that all these people were
federal agents i don't believe that to
be the case i think some of them let me
give you the facts that the media is
presenting and what it is that they are
not presenting so there were members
they said traveled from 11 states
uh with the intent to riot conspiracy to
riot to ida in idaho a pride event a gay
pride event
in idaho in idaho just yeah where
obviously the biggest pride event will
be held right right and here are some of
the things that well first off they were
all wearing this is overlay see they
were all wearing khakis blue shirts
beige hats white and that's why you're
like well they're
they're wearing the fed uniform pretty
much you know they're glowing from here
but here are some things that don't
really add up let me just give you some
information here that to me doesn't make
sense so they were pulled over in a
u-haul truck okay conspiracy to riot
if these people first off how do you
know conspiracy to riot these people
have showed up i guess members of
patriot front and they've marched and
they're racist and of course we can if
we condem any viewpoint that would
believe a race is superior inferior okay
we of course we all agree with that
also but if someone is being peaceful if
they're not burning down cities you
can't tell them
who to love and who to hate yeah we also
don't like to talk about this
people have the right to hate it's wrong
we believe this is christians that you
shouldn't hate people you should be a
lover of people yeah people have the
right to hate but when you think about
it
the u-haul truck this is something wait
hold on a second they came in from 11
states all 30-something people in the
back of a u-haul truck so this is
something that is not only unsafe
impractical they would all have to
escape in one vehicle where someone
would have had to provide their license
and a security deposit
[Music]
it's hard to get away with it is it am i
the only one who says there's something
fishy going on there something else the
names have been made available right for
the men who have been involved
no outlet has reported on previous
criminal records for anyone now that
could change yeah
but if they release all the names of
people involved you should be able to
find pretty quickly the name to state
their criminal records their
affiliations because this is some if
it's a sting it means they've been
monitoring them for a long time which
would mean there was previous activity
yeah um and again this is the same group
they marched in dc
right racist
no incident yeah so they were monitoring
the group or the u-haul they just rented
right
that's the point if you rent a u-haul
you're probably not looking to commit a
federal crime because you have to take
that u-haul back well of course no it it
it makes perfect sense what is this all
over well blood i'm sorry about that
does that is that covered by the deposit
yeah i hope no that's not the
conversation also this is the one that
was used in the giant hate crime and i
don't know oh
no this is a covered mask no i just i
wear it everywhere yeah right it's all
white and by the way here's the police
captain discussing you know i said they
were tipped off here's a clip do you
know what the original stop was for
said we have informants three informants
right
it's tough to hear some people say three
informants or we have informants but i
don't know if three means literally all
of patriot front there's gonna say like
three and there's what four of them yeah
like three four all of them i don't know
three fourths of them yes that's what it
is somebody with the cdl they got off of
craigslist right
by the way one of the weirdest things
about this is this was everywhere like i
thought they stopped a terrorist attack
because it was like it was trending on
twitter it was all over all the news
agencies and i'm like oh man what
happened here it's like oh they had
intent to write what does that mean well
they had one i think smoke grenade and
then they had they had like shields yeah
it's like oh huh i don't know if you
know this but typically speaking shields
are a defensive tool yeah yeah yeah so
it seems like more so they were maybe
anticipating people attacking them which
again i have no idea but the point is
typically rent a u-haul you don't rent a
u-haul truck to commit a hate crime on
national television
and and by the way i i mean there's
there's so many things here that just
don't add up okay and here's the thing
even if you disagree and you think that
it is deplorable in the actual sense i'm
not saying basket of deplorables but
deplorable for someone to actually
believe in racial inferiority yeah um
you still have to acknowledge that these
people
should not be arrested if they haven't
committed this is a very minority report
s yeah you guys comment below and let me
know what you think of course i'm not
going to agree with the ideology of the
worldview i condemn it outright you know
i'm not going to say it again because
you know where i line up but the issue
here is
intent
to riot conspiracy
to riot and i also think the double
standard does matter here and this is
where
like you said you'd think they thwarted
a terrorist attack yeah and when i
finally read i might was like 20 20 dad
bods and khakis well that's the thing
that's interesting they're gonna go
interrupt a gay pride parade but they
make sure they all match right yes
exactly not to mention the handbags yeah
it's very strange and the handbags
didn't have any weapons no they were
just
an accessory yeah that's it empty right
they were really going to pick up dudes
oh
it's a big coming-out party yeah
they were just sky they're telling their
wives like we're going to go hate on
yeah right hate on them real hard all
weekend but you know what's this is the
thing with the left and this is the
divide and conquer i will tell you this
what is my fear i said this in 2015 when
you had the original black lives matter
sort of riots taking place yeah and you
were there back then i said look i am
concerned that i grew up in a
post-racial america you know we had
fresh prince of bel air we had family
met our our top content if you look at
musical artists culturally we're black
it was white people consuming that
content we really did grow up in a are
there individual racists sure but a
post-racial america and i said you are
going to create more racism than ever
because you're reintroducing this to a
generation especially by guilting people
especially by guilting young white
children particularly young white males
for something that they over which they
have no control
and then you see the unequal treatment
of people like these patriot front
awful okay got it group that we don't
like but the treatment of them compared
to the treatment of yes a domestic
terror organization who now have
multi-million dollar mansions like black
lives matter who by the way uh committed
well we'll get to this billions of
dollars in damages and we're given room
quote this is our leaders black lives
matter they were rioting burning down
cities and they were given room to rage
room to destroy
and we've had these types of
conversations
before and i've made it very clear
that i
worked with the police and instructed
them to do everything that they could
to make sure that the protesters were
able to exercise their right to free
speech
it's a very delicate balancing act
because while we
try to make sure that they were
protected from the cars and the other
you know things that were going on
we also gave those who wished to destroy
space to do that as well we have arrived
at at a point in our country that we
should recognize this is not just a
moment it is a movement
it is a movement that is fueled
by the the diversity the beautiful
diversity of who we are coming together
as a unified body
uh demanding in this case change and
justice for everyone if you see anybody
from that cabinet in a restaurant
in a department store
at a gasoline station you get out and
you create a crowd
and you push back on them
and you tell them they're not welcome
and of course uh that'll bring us to our
next segment but before i do that look
uh i have no idea how long we'll be on
youtube we've talked about this with you
we are off this month of july dave and i
have some solo dates we'll be announcing
our major fall tour tomorrow but it's a
live show monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern if we don't tell you that we are
not on you can watch on rumble or you
can watch on mug club where we have two
times the show
that's not 50 more show that's a hundred
percent more show yeah double show
double show that's math it's a double
feature thank god it's not a jurassic
it's science martha's race
well it can be yes not an arc and by can
be i mean it always is but this brings
us now speaking of black lives matter
riots uh versus january 6th to gerald no
sports
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
so i like his other stinger yeah i think
his other stinger is better we should
make them more like that so this is tell
set this up for us it's so washington
commanders you know the people that used
to be called the washington redskins but
went woke when nobody really cared and
right yeah the commanders commanders is
going to have to be changed in 10 years
would
yeah isn't someone in charge not a lot
of someone's anyway yeah otherwise you
just end up like a bunch of commanders
with your head's covered pretty much yes
presidents yeah the jack del rio the
defensive coordinator was just fined 100
000 by the team for his comments about
january what sounds like they must be
spicy must be yeah well let's see just
be an opinion right maybe i don't know
but he was fine a hundred thousand
dollars for his opinions on january 6th
and comparing it to the billions of
dollars in damages of black class matter
rice a very actually and by the way
people make insensitive comparisons all
the time guilty
this wasn't one of them i think we have
a clip yeah you want to talk about it
i'd talk about with anybody yeah no
problem at any time but uh
but they're not
i'm just expressing myself and uh i
think we all as americans have the right
to express ourselves especially if
you're being respectful
i'm being respectful
i just asked the simple question really
did i
let's get right down to it what did i
ask
a simple question
why are we not
looking into those things if we're going
to talk about it
why are we not looking into those things
talking about this matter right
i can
realistically look at it i see the
images on tv
people's livelihoods are being destroyed
businesses are being burned down
no problem
and then we have a dust up at the
capitol
well there's nothing burned down and
we're not going to talk about we're
going to make that a major deal i just
think
it got two standards
and if we apply the same standard
and we're going to be reasonable with
each other let's have a discussion
that's all it was let's have a
discussion we're americans let's talk it
through now i don't know anything about
sports outside of combat sports that's
you know people know this everyone mocks
me for it rightfully so
um
i'm so glad that it doesn't hurt me to
not have to watch the nba the nfl i'm so
glad that it's not something that i miss
because you have to you can't say okay
i'm gonna boycott disney and cancel my
subscription and still give money to
these organizations a hundred thousand
dollars he was fined i thought it might
be a joke no by his own team by his own
team for this tweet he wrote would love
to understand the whole story about why
the summer of riots looting burning and
the destruction of personal property is
never discussed but this is and that was
in response to january 6th that's an
entirely valid question
yeah absolutely and i think the problem
that you saw there the only the only
words was dust up dust up is what
everybody grabbed onto in his june 8th
response to the tweet that you just read
because everybody was up in arms about
it like hey what are you talking about
he comes out and responds with that like
a dust stuff happens and everybody's
like oh you're calling the threat to
democracy a dust up call it a brouhaha
and grow whatever it is you know the
only person who was killed who was that
oh well hold on you're you're
foreshadowing right now right so let me
just go over some of the things really
quickly because we know
big hearings going on right now about
the the worst threat to our democracy
ever
much less the right so january 6 versus
blm let's talk about money right blm
right it's one to two billion dollars i
believe that was within two weeks of the
george floyd institute yeah that was in
2020 and they've never updated the
numbers even though the riots have not
stopped yeah absolutely they'll call it
at least a cool three billion but back
then it was too big yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but that's a billion between
friends it doesn't count the millions
given to the organization by that i mean
a couple women right yeah right who know
how their homes bailer mansions by the
way january 6 2.73 million dollars in
damages not even enough to buy one of
those mansions right in bel air i'm
saying you need money you could give
that amount of money to one of the heads
of the black lives matter chapters like
i'm supposed to deal with this [ __ ]
so what are you gonna do bob pool house
come on well i mean listen you know it
does take money for that but if it's not
just money if you're talking about
people hurt and talking about deaths
understandably right let's talk about
that right so in the two weeks following
george floyd incident there were 19
people who were killed
a majority of those victims were black
people more than a thousand officer
casualties all references available by
the way louder with crowder.com yeah and
then uh on january 6 despite what we
were told
initially and then initially the
corrections that didn't correct it there
was one person that was killed she was
shot while jumping through a window her
name was ashley babbitt was not entirely
obvious that that person needed to be
shot there was no special investigation
that everybody got to see like every
other story we've heard fine whatever
can you pause real quick because a lot
of people and
if you you watch regularly or you're
listening on audio you listen regularly
you know this a huge percentage of
americans don't
they don't know they believe that four
or five officers were killed including
officer brian siknik who died of natural
or potentially self-inflicted causes
right yeah this is it's not true
even the people on the side of the left
the people who've been running the
investigations our own intelligence
agencies who would really want this to
be true had to say okay it's not true
none of these office officers were
actually killed right but that's also
why it's so pernicious because the
sports illustrated article when i was
reading this about del rio it still
promotes the this this narrative that
four people died because of the riot
well listen to these are journalists
yeah listen how they phrase it now
though they're actually just adjoining
these two things they're saying because
of the riot not at the riot they weren't
killed during the riot but it was
because of the strain or stress of the
riot those deaths are attributable to
the riot
oh i wonder if there was any deaths from
stress related to losing people's
livelihoods or just from being shot by
people at the black lives matter protest
directly yeah i can't imagine being shot
is also stressful that's also stabbed
and
being lit on fire yeah
things that actually happened you know
repeatedly yeah who knows though who
knows the world will never know no the
world will well no that's right the
world does know oh right that's right
the world does know they just want to
lie anyway right now with their stupid
grandstanding i watched the january 6th
i did too on thursday committee hearing
it's nonsense and i watched it here's
the thing i'm going you went through the
hours and hours of footage
now i was as pissed as anyone i'm going
look you shouldn't be sitting there at
nancy pelosi's desk you're an ass you
deserve to be arrested for trespassing
got it
that's it
okay that's about where it at this was
stupid a few you know a couple hundred
people got out of control those people
should face repercussions for
trespassing on yeah i was on we were all
on board with that but then i'm watching
this i'm going they went through all of
the footage keep in mind they they're
making a case right they are presenting
their strongest case possible i'm going
my god hold on a second i'm looking at
this and
they pushed down a barricade and then
the people's house someone threw a trash
can
i'm going is this it is this what you've
got yeah no not one fire was lit like
they didn't bring some black cats or
anything
well and let's say allegedly there's
footage of a police officer waving you
in wouldn't that kind of
take away the trespassing charge i mean
if there were such a thing for some of
them which it does right which we've
shown the people's house but anyway i
digress and the fact that it's public
property what let's go back to the nfl
because the nfl like this by the way
jack del rio if he doesn't like simmer
down on this he will be out of a job in
a heartbeat because the nfl will put
their foot down on this but nothing else
right because they're going to piss off
well that's also keep in mind the nfl is
also um remember colin kaepernick said
yeah it's it's slavery and he just
repeatedly wants to audition for slavery
he does because apparently being drafted
to be a slave it's tough these things
then he passed men who looked the most
like slaves yes the slave master came
out from roots like now you listen here
which one of you is going to be my
strongest oh pick me pick me colin
kaepernick pick me pick me no i want
myself a good slave who can actually
play pick me i want to be a slave i want
to be a slave it's just laughable
slavery you don't audition for slavery
you run and then they usually catch you
with a net anyways it's horrible
well and then they really don't give you
millions and millions of dollars nike
contracts right well and they don't time
your 40.
they shoot you while you're running
that's the thing that's alright you
interesting
contract according to ravens hall of
famer ed reed the hundred thousand
dollar fine is not enough this is the
problem it's a doggy piling now right
exactly so i'll read the quote today i'm
sick and tired a dust up 100 000 is not
enough money ain't nothing to a person
who is recycled through coaching not
sure what that means uh it's always one
first it was saban now it's jack to just
remind us what it is man if you coached
by him put your pants on
it's simple right and wrong wrong that
doesn't make i don't even i can't
decipher what he's trying to say he's
upset okay i think i think that's what i
need to take from it all right and so
obviously you know keith olbermann this
person is totally sane person took to
twitter and said at nfl you have to ban
coach del rio today enough of these it
was a dust up fantasizers 1-6 deniers
defenders of sedition and
bull stuff
get that son of a bee off the field this
isn't free speech ah oh this argument
this isn't free speech he's a private
employee wait a minute i'm sorry when
colin kaepernick was doing his thing
when ed reed was doing his thing with a
bunch of players in the nfl doing their
thing and we said no no no you can't do
that you said oh it's free speech right
we were like no he's a private employee
right keith olbermann are you now on our
side that free speech does exist and by
the way i'm not creating a false
equivalency because just to be clear
here i think what colin kaepernick did
was far worse and more uninformed saying
that the united states is a country
based on slavery that he won't stand for
an unjust country and then uh
auditioning for the organization that
he's claimed is basically a slavery
combine i don't even know what that
means i think that's far dumber
and far more offensive to the basic
human being's intellect of average
intelligence mind you than saying hey
why can't we ask about the black lives
matter riots that were billions of
dollars in damages thousands of
casualties with officers alone thousands
of arrests over 19 deaths in the two
weeks why can't we talk about those
they prove his point why can't we ask
questions about those things and only
talk about this dustup that had taken
place january 6. and what do they do
they immediately punish him for talking
about those things and i i i will bet
money right now that he has fired before
the season starts i guarantee you oh you
guys have no balls whatsoever especially
these guys so and then nbc sports uh
mike florio the wokest of the woke perry
did the end double acp calls to have him
fired he couldn't be outdone oh
washington commanders defensive
coordinator jack del rio calling the
january 6 insurrection a dust up earlier
this week and also making the false
equivalence to the riots that happened
in the aftermath of the murder of george
floyd and others
multiple examples of police violence
directed to minorities in 2020 and the
organic reaction to that
the president of the naacp said
yesterday it's time for del rio to
resign or be
fired okay so let me just explain a
couple of things here well first off
let's recap this the coaches find a
hundred thousand dollars for downplaying
january 6 which killed zero black people
the only person who was killed was an
old white broad by the way an older
white broad who was a trump supporter
who was going through a window and it
was completely an unnecessary shoot
pretty much everyone agrees on that if
you've actually looked at the floor so
this nfl has fined a hundred thousand
dollars but uh the same organization
celebrates black lives matter which has
led to
dozens of deaths largely black people
when you're talking about citizens let
alone officers and let alone the black
officers who have been uh the victim of
these casualties at the hands of this
domestic terrorist organization but here
is the point that i think really matters
we just talked about the patriot front
it's absurd hopefully they're relegated
to the history books as this failed
drinking club
the problem that you run into and i've
said this before is you are going to
breed extremism when we used to talk
about this where we used to talk about
people who were actual white
supremacists right they would say hey
don't push them all the way to the edge
that they have no way back because
that's when you make them more extreme
you want to try and pull them back but
now we are literally saying hey shove
everyone off of the playing field me and
also the field of discussion push them
so far to the edge just for pointing out
that cities were destroyed by black
lives matter and guess what guess what
happens with this people are afraid to
speak out because they'll be fined they
get picked off so people as individuals
say we literally can't even ask
questions about these or you know my
business was burned down but what i
don't want to have happen is me be fired
for my new jobs so they become silent
they speak in quiet and then they feel
like in order to just be safe and i
don't mean physically safe in order to
maintain their livelihood they need to
become a part of a group and guess what
you just served as recruiting for the
white supremacists that you claimed you
hate
just as black lives matter serves as
recruiting
for financial frauds and grifters this
is what happens when you push we used to
say don't push people too far who are
already pretty extreme and now we are
saying let's present even mainstream
views mainstream black views by the way
of black lives matter and defund the
police to be clear all the references
are available at loudcrowder.com we have
that polling data from black americans
the vast majority don't believe in
defunding the police and weren't big
fans of the organization let's push all
of these people off of the ideological
playing field let's push them to the
wings of extremism and then be surprised
and [ __ ] about the fact that we're
divided more than ever here in the
united states
if someone if this is an offense worthy
of a 100 dollar fine
guess what
the nfl has said
you as a mainstream unless you are a
radical leftist who believes that black
lives matter is fault faultless
blameless as mike florio just said the
the uh what do you say the uh the false
equivalence what do you say the
illegitimate comparison well i guess
you're right because one was very
violent and destroyed livelihoods and
the entire country tore us apart and the
other one was uh i don't know let's call
it a hootenanny that took place with a
couple hundred people and no one was
killed
at the capitol let's just be clear about
that it is an entirely illegitimate
comparison because of how violent black
lives matter has been not only do i
think this not only does everyone in
this room think this the vast majority
of americans believe this and you have
said that they are not welcome to have a
seat at the table they are not welcome
to play in major sports organizations
and they are not welcome to even be on
mainstream media platforms nor social
media platforms where do you expect them
to go how do you expect them to evolve
from here it's only going to get worse
if you don't let anyone speak especially
when it's as rational as this but
comment below i want to hear from you
what is if this is an affront
worthy of finding what could he have
possibly said
is there any way
that del rio could have criticized the
black lives matter riots is there any
way that he could have criticized the
media that wouldn't have resulted in a
fine i don't know is there a way he
could have phrased it i can't think of
it that's how far we are this has been
thank you so much sorry i had to go with
it there gerald no sports and i don't
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i know
it's so frustrating because you're right
you're making it to where people can't
even have a dialogue he he was the most
respectful that i've heard in that like
i think we as americans we can talk
about this stuff we can talk about it
respectfully
a dust-up happens you know why he said
that
because you said it was the greatest
attack on democracy ever do you know
what they were protesting for for mike
pence to send the vote back to the
states
that was it yeah they didn't change
anything it could potentially change
something well what is that definition
of a dust-up
because i think that it would probably
fit the definition if you look at it
it's just they think he's minimizing it
and triple it but i don't think he is i
think that if you look at what it is it
is a it's a fight it's a giant fight
yeah i don't think it's something that
it i don't think it's downplaying it i
think they're just trying to make you
think it's downplayed well they're
trying to make you think it that this
was donald trump trying to overthrow a
duly elected president which has never
happened in our history before and
that's not what it was i mean he called
the riot a riot
right right he called the other thing a
dust up which is what essentially it was
yeah yeah can we can we talk about maybe
nancy pelosi with their election of duty
and all this
stuff anybody well they they they
crapped on her desk and i'm like that's
not true that was the it's it's amber
heard me i was about to yeah yeah they
crafted somebody cramped in her driveway
the fake news center all this other
stuff yeah and all this other stuff in
the media has made people think that but
so many people have asked me like but
they did crap on her desk right and i'm
like no i wish but they didn't but let's
even say yeah so let's even say someone
crapped on her desk is that reason to be
jailed for months without trial
forfeiting your rights for sedition
because you left a grumpy on the
speaker's desk yeah
three years because you wore a stupid
hat right if you had fred flintstone if
you attacked a cop
if you even if you assaulted a cop right
or bad i don't even know what the terms
are but you cause harm to one of the
police officers you should be tried for
it yup you should be charged immediately
i'm sorry i don't care how pissed off
you got you should be tried for it deal
if you walked into the capitol among a
crowd of people and they want to charge
you with trespassing fine i'm sure
you'll pay the 200 fine
i have i have trespassing charges do you
well no warnings when we did one of the
crowder confronts at that juice land
they called you know the person who
slammed for one year the juice land in
austin for one year the cops were like
hey what's going on i said well i wasn't
trespassing when you know they said they
were going to call the police i wanted
to speak with you i had a i had a
bristol board yeah with all the threats
to slash my tires and firebomb the car
and i was like by the way here's a thumb
drive so you have it this is all the
information that you need and all of
their personal information he was like
all right just don't come back to don't
come back to juice land for a year i'm
like i can't go to any city he's like no
just this juice land you're actually
finding that other side of the sidewalk
just just for one year and i was like oh
okay all right that's fine enough to pay
or anything he's like no you have to pay
anything just don't come back officer i
don't ever think i was intending to come
to a juice land again no i was going to
confront that person again if they if
they moved up to middle management of
juice land
every time i get a promotion that is
fair because i'm petty and small-minded
by the way uh dave and i are on uh we're
on tour this is the last of our dates
together here you can go ladder with
crowder.com tour colorado springs
yesterday we just released i think a
couple hundred tickets yeah because we
often hold some tickets for walk ups
yeah
yeah com they're called comps for um is
it june 18th this saturday
dot com slash tour and then we will be
announcing our major fall tour uh
tomorrow dave and i
uh okay this is one we're gonna send it
back over to me here
because i don't know sports but i do
know canada yes
oh canada
oh canada this is why this is why i'm in
this chair
[Music]
if you make an a joke i swear to you i
will murder you where you stand like
with
where you sit yeah yeah i i really wanna
you won't you won't go home
no homey
i won't do it on air because i need
cupboard
canadian neckties
yeah
so over the weekend and this is
important i always tell people uh canada
is a very important petri dish
because a lot of americans understand
these laws that exist in other
commonwealth countries where they don't
have the constitution of the united
states uh and in canada this is very
closely you don't have to go all the way
over to europe and you would be
surprised when you go to canada just how
american it seems in so many ways on its
surface and then you go just a couple
layers deeper and you realize that the
rights you take for granted on a daily
basis
are one brush of the pen away
from going away forever
so over the weekend prime minister
justin trudeau said that
uh gun rights as they relate to
self-defense
don't exist in canada
we're introducing legislation to
implement
a national freeze
on handgun ownership
okay sorry we got the wrong clip i
apologize that's not him but here is uh
prime minister uh justin trudeau saying
that uh you have no right to
self-defense with firearms in canada
yeah and there are debates and we have a
culture where the difference is guns can
be used for hunting or for sport
shooting in canada and there's lots of
gun owners and they're
mostly lost respecting and law abiding
but you can't use a gun for
self-protection in canada that's not a
right that you have either the
constitution or anywhere else if you try
and buy a gun he says for
self-protection no you don't get that
you get it for hunting you can get it
for sport shooting take it to the range
as long as you go through he's giving
you permission ground checks but there's
a difference around the culture and one
of the things that we're seeing with the
debate in the states is you get more and
more of the american style you know
right to carry self-defense arguments
filtering up through through the uh you
know the usual more right-wing
communications channels yeah yeah crazy
by the way that's a good thing i like
that he says more right wing because
he's saying those crazy right wingers
believe that you have the right to
defend your home and your wife and your
private property we don't believe that
here in canada keep in mind
when you're talking about the second
amendment when you're looking at the
actual case law when you're looking at
uh heller versus dc look at the
dissenting opinions here in the united
states it was you have no right to
private citizens have no right to own a
firearm whatsoever so when people on the
left are saying ah the second
amendment's not absolute which is why
that was the question of the day what
they're they're not saying we need an
assault weapons ban
they're not saying we should have a
waiting period which by the way i'm also
against they're saying that private
citizens don't have the right to own a
firearm whatsoever because we've
misinterpreted the constitution
therefore
we become exactly like canada and he is
saying you get it for hunting who he
grants it keep in mind these [ __ ]
still have the royalty on their money so
he's saying we grant it i allow you to
i'm tired of canadians acting as though
they're better than the united states we
fought off the royalty because we didn't
believe in them that's why we left you
bent the knee you're a nation founded on
cowardice and i say this as a canadian
with great shame canada is a nation
founded on cowardice the united states
is a nation founded upon a violent
revolution
violence is not immoral
that's immoral
robbing people of the right to defend
themselves is immoral you want to know
what else is immoral let me give you a
few examples of what has happened in
canada we're not the rapist the murderer
the criminal the home invader being
punished
but the defender of their own life and
livelihood punished so we have after uh
after being stabbed in the head while
sleeping vincent bunn stabbed his
assailant to death he was sleeping
stabbed in the head he stabbed the other
guy who was stabbing well he was
sentenced for murder
the man who was stabbed in his sleep
yeah i think if someone stabs you in
your sleep you can do whatever you want
you can do whatever you want to that guy
i don't give a rat's ass what you do
with the corpse yeah leave
fold it
like a pizza slice and put it in the
bird feeder for all like he was stabbing
you in your sleep in canada you get
arrested if you stab back
yeah and to be fair they said he stabbed
him too many times the 13th stab is what
actually killed him because they were
still fighting and then kicked him a
couple of times after that
that was what oh well he was dead and
you kicked him a couple of times right
that's interesting then there's ian
thompson he fired three rounds from a
revolver to scare off
uh a group who was firebombing his home
what happened he was the one charged
with pointing a firearm along with two
counts of careless storage of a firearm
actually i don't think that was careless
i think that was very prudent storage
because you were able to access your
firearm when your home was being
firebombed right and by the way joe
biden said fire two shots in the air he
did it into the ground are essentially
the same thing come on yeah get your
story straight guys brian knight he's
fighting fire with fire right really i
mean you should be allowed to
whatever i want to fight fire with death
of those lighting the fire yeah they're
lucky they didn't get shot yes i have no
problem with someone setting a fire fire
bombing someone's house or personal
property
i have no problem
with the victim shooting them and i
don't see the people committing the
crime even if they were killed to be
victims i prefer it you you forfeit your
right to live when you do that brian
knight
another man in canada convicted after
shooting a man who was attempting to
steal his atv just to be clear this is
one of those things where you know what
hey i believe if someone is on your
property trying to steal destroy your
stuff and i'm i tried to go in
descending order with the most absurd
you have people in the uk by the way as
well who've been arrested for using fake
guns for instilling fear in home
invaders
this is what happens in the countries
where the second amendment isn't
absolute and the arrogance that you see
with that prime minister blackface by
the way is no one going to did he just
get a pass on that megan kelly was fired
because she said that when she was a kid
she dressed up like diana ross for
halloween and this guy gets to do
blackface 1900 times and no one cares
this is the guy who's now in control of
your right to defend your own life and
limb you guys don't see a problem with
this you don't have that right remember
in canada you don't you don't have it i
can give it to you for hunting uh you
know if you uh if you kiss the ring
how is he allowed to just make all these
decisions just him
uh well it's canada and it's absurd it's
amazing though i i i he has no effect on
me personally right and i've never hated
someone so much yeah i know what you
mean and it's wrong to hate it is wrong
to hate but i get it but i mean as far
as costuming goes great at blackface
he's fantastic yeah really the best he
really commits to it yes because he
doesn't just do blackface he does black
arms he does black legs he goes all the
way he goes all the way well this is
what happens when you trust in the
bollywood movie right this is what
happens when you trust them and you say
look we're going to give you all the
power that we want and we're scared and
the government needs to take care of us
it just listen but i don't know that
anybody would have said that justin
trudeau like you couldn't fit him for a
black hat early on right you could
probably say if you knew justin trudeau
be like oh he's probably not gonna be a
good prime minister but now it's like
wait he's literally saying you have no
right to defend yourself with a firearm
or property really by extension right at
all like it doesn't exist how many steps
further do you think he could possibly
go and by the way this i should be clear
this isn't new he's just reiterating
what what i have communicated here and
people said that's a strong man it's not
i've lived it i lived there i know it
and it's gotten worse and it's getting
worse and this guy is arrogant about it
and guess what you just need the supreme
court to tilt the wrong direction or you
pack it
and the wrong person in the white house
for that to happen right here and i'm
not talking about ar-15s for people who
are going ooh you love to separate oh
ar-15s because you don't know anything
about firearms
your revolver yeah your basic handgun
your pump shotgun
your hunting rifle
it will be rendered useless for
self-defense because that's what they
have done
everywhere not named the united states
of america and by the way speaking of
this in the united states michael moore
who looks like a transitioning walter
white would like america to adopt this
exact same position uh here he is on
msnbc saying that we don't need guns and
we'll have them here in studio i think
that we need some really drastic action
here
um we need a moratorium perhaps on gun
sales um we need to who will say on this
network or any other network in the next
few days it's time to repeal the second
amendment
sorry i'm just writing down i'm writing
down a note that he's an [ __ ]
oh i told you that uh those are some
pretty rough
i mean no i want to say it's not at all
something that i didn't expect uh i wish
i could say i'm surprised but look
respect to anyone who's willing to reach
across the aisle and have a conversation
as extreme as he may be wanted to bring
in michael moore to explain our home
state of michigan and uh here he is
we'll bring him in studio
[Music]
all right so this is over the weekend uh
of course michael moore uh we just
showed you said we have to repeal the
second amendment um here he is to
explain
uh his point of view michael moore thank
you uh thank you for being here sir you
guys need ramps
there are so many stairs here we
actually we don't have any stairs in the
studio we just have the we don't have oh
it's a curb really really yeah it's a
step
well this place isn't ada compliant i
had to park my mobility scooter outside
oh i didn't know that was a well it was
actually just a forklift with a free
willy uh hammock potato potato that's my
truth okay um
but uh let's get down to it you think
the second amendment should be repealed
yes i've always been anti-gun but now
i've had enough
and have you you've had enough that
something he's probably never said after
a meal
i've closed down more restaurants than
coke hey hey hey are you shaming me
a little bit okay well steven listen you
guys all making fun of me because i'm a
fat person is just low hanging fruit
which is also
which is also the only thing i won't eat
you don't really strike me as a
vegetable guy either right veggie what
oh they're an edible type of uh plant it
doesn't it doesn't really matter to your
other point you think that no one should
have guns uh mr moore do you agree with
the prime minister just because
it seems your justification is you don't
like them 70 of us do not own firearms
we are not a nation of gun owners we are
actually absolutely a nation of gun
owners and we have the right to defend
ourselves and your stat is not correct
then i say gun shouldn't be in the home
we should do what other countries do and
store them at the gun range similar to
how i store travel sandwiches in amazon
lockers all across america wait what
what's a travel site what is that what's
a travel center well those are
sandwiches that i make
to take on the road with me when i go on
adventures to get fast food i would
imagine that those sandwiches are the
amazon lockers are first floor amazon
lockers yeah i can't go use stairs right
so you make a sam hold on a second i
want to make sure i understand you make
a sandwich
to go pick up food yes a travel sandwich
you are
an absolute animal
you're disgusting human being but let's
get back on track so safely keeping a
gun in your house by the way is what
makes sense people keeping firearms in
their home not in travel sandwich
lockers if someone breaks in then get a
dog well i have both a gun and a dog
yeah pick one no there's no reason that
responsible gunner chef that's the thing
i i think you should get a dog i think a
dog is better than a gun but you should
have both and you don't have the right
to take and you have the right to both
yeah well let me explain it like this
okay okay it's just an analogy all right
yes you brought a snack now
let's uh imagine
okay hold on first let me get all the
gross stuff off of here yeah all the all
the vegetables oh that's what those are
yes that's what yeah okay now let's
imagine this triple whopper is the
second amendment okay we've got a triple
triple whopper yeah and we made those so
we're just gonna take it apart bite by
bite all right so uh bump stocks
don't have those no more oh god
nine millimeter pistols can't have that
might blow our own well at least that
work
you just came here to eat a burger
didn't you michael moore
yeah
all right let's that's enough get out of
here yeah that's disgusting
[Music]
all right that guy needs to go on a diet
again uh something uh stephen and i as
ambassadors for the state of michigan
would like to apologize for michael
moore what else we have on several
occasions you know he's going to come
out it's never enough in a couple years
as a woman
calling it now
i thought he already was
i guarantee you you're probably right
him i think him and stephen king are
actually going to be a lesbian couple
that own a bookstore
just be going and shopping like a bass
pro you're like stephen king and michael
moore you're bullshitting this is where
we buy our shirts and king and more
books
we still stand with ukraine i mean i
don't stand but you know i'll sit with
ukraine for a while that's the ukraine
rainbow flag i made it to the grand
canyon hover around just keep going
there needs to be a ramp yeah crying out
loud we don't have steps here all right
yes i can see it from the car right
some pictures just you go just leave
keep the air running keep the air
running
travel sandwiches now max max air
that's where it recycles the air oh my
gosh
so it gets my musk
i only found that out recently by the
way that max air is recycling the inside
air i thought it was i didn't know
yeah i don't know how these things work
i'm not a mechanic all i know is it's
colder so speaking of crazy people who i
don't like let's move on to aoc oh this
is wonderful and this is [ __ ]
this is something that is concerning
at first it's funny yes
then it's concerning when you understand
no one by the way is uh willing in the
dnc right now to endorse biden it's it's
a trend you're seeing like well i don't
know
that's worrisome because i don't want uh
we're talking about the next election
right 2024 i don't want it to be for the
democrats anyone else yeah i i want it
to be joe biden i am donating to joe
biden for america yes i want him to be
the nominee right
but don't actually donate to joe biden
for america no let's not do that but i
understand i understand the principle so
here's aoc uh being asked directly and
clearly unnerved as to whether or not
she will support or endorse former vice
president joe biden i just want to ask
about president biden he is saying he's
going to run again in 2024 will you
support him
you know if the president chooses uh to
run again in 2024 i mean first of all
i'm focused on winning this majority
right now uh and preserving a majority
this year in 2022 so we'll cross that
bridge when we get to it but um but i
think if if the president has a vision
and that's something certainly we're all
willing to entertain and examine when
the when the time comes
that's not a yes
dana
yeah you know i think we should
endorse when we get to it but i i
believe that the president has been
doing a very good job uh so far and um
you know should he run again i think
that i you know i think it's it's
we'll take a look at it
okay so right now we need to focus on
winning a majority instead of a
presidential election you said this is
going to be a softball dana yeah by the
way you don't win a majority when you
already have a majority it's called
maintaining the majority or expanding
well gerald the thing is she's [ __ ]
and she says we'll cross that bridge
when we come to it that's just like
we'll cross the bridge when we come to
it because endorsing biden is a the
bridge over river why i guess that's
what's happening
so i can't blame her
she moves like a cartoon like she's she
moves like you can tell she was raised
by disney and nickelodeon right now like
she's a cartoon character right and her
eyes i just every time i see him i i
jump back right it's because she's on
ecstasy she has to aoc give a surprise i
am just these giants already there
yeah she's and she's very clearly upset
i don't know that's not a yes
dana
don't call me out oh my god coming to
the side of dana bash's screen
it's just a noose just starts
there's no evidence that he's gonna run
again by the way
she was so under prepared for that who
is on her staff not pain like you might
get a question just say we're not
talking about that yet we're focused on
the midterms and move on they're too
busy mixing daiquiris yeah well
i love that they didn't prepare don't
get me wrong that was wonderful well
this is the problem we've talked about
this
right yes sorry the left this is the
problem with is they don't fear any kind
of accountability so in the rare
instance where and they didn't they
didn't have a meeting this is the
problem they didn't have a meeting i
guarantee you dana bash wouldn't impress
her if she knew that it was going to be
a problem right but they didn't have a
meeting here as far as well when we say
softball do we mean no follow-up
questions and unfortunately dana bash
was just trying to give her the
opportunity saying that's not a yes
because she thought
the aoc would say well yes of course and
instead aoc didn't want to endorse biden
because she must have seen some recent
polling data you know from anywhere and
so she was afraid she didn't want to she
didn't want to uh to fall on that sword
dana bash didn't really know she thought
she was teeing it up for aoc because
they are used to being teed up trust me
when you are when you think that there
are these people who are experts whether
it's in media whether it's in academia
whether it's often in science or
politics
we've talked about you know when you're
an adult you when you're a kid you think
that adults all know what they're doing
and then you grow up and you become an
adult and you realize i don't really
know what i'm doing i know what i'm
doing a little bit more than a
six-year-old but i don't know what i'm
doing nearly as much as i believed other
adults did when i was six it's that only
more severe with the experts
particularly in areas like uh
politics and education you know areas
where there's no actual profit bottom
line where someone can look at numbers
on a sheet and say okay this either
worked or it didn't
that's what you just saw happening there
yeah absolutely and look she's she's
saying what everybody's thinking right
now right you guys sold us the lie that
it was the most popular president
american history had more votes than
anybody else he's the savior of our
country and that the economy is doing
fantastic and we just don't know it yet
and then you had to come straight up to
terms with he sucks and nobody likes him
the polling shows that the stock market
right now is in the midst of crashing no
literally right now further i mean
literally right literally right what
happened what happened it was down 700
something points it's been up i think as
high as down 850 or so points and it's
like well 8.6 inflation last week will
do that and so many negative outlooks on
the economy including the president who
said that inflation was just gonna be a
momentary thing saying hey this may be
around for first he said it was good
well he said it was a good thing then he
said it's well you know it's something
we're just getting now he's saying
there's nothing we can do about
inflation so you're paying record gas
prices you're dealing with record
inflation you're dealing with a horribly
screwed up job market by that i mean
there are actually jobs available that
people don't want to apply for because
they've been conditioned and paid to not
work for a while and now we're dealing
with that fallout we're probably going
to actually find ourselves at the point
of a labor shortage the housing market
has been artificially manipulated which
we're now seeing correcting correcting
itself somewhat we don't know whether it
will correct itself entirely because of
vanguard percentage rate and uh yeah the
mortgage rates here are going way up uh
we just saw the most amount of homes
that they have made available on the
market in a month-to-month jump since i
believe it was june
2008 but certainly before the 2008 crash
that'll probably be manipulated by too
big to fail organizations like vanguard
blackrock so we don't know what's going
to happen there but you are living this
right now everything is more expensive
you have less money and oh wait a second
what are they covering right now let's
look at cnn what are they doing right
now what's the priority from this white
house is covering a dare i say it dust
up from january 6. let's see what
they're doing right now expand you know
political ideologies from trump to
mccain to bush
to christie
okay so they're continuing now with this
political theater so don't worry about
gas prices your future your children's
future your ability to make a living
that your savings is going down the
[ __ ] because we need to get down to
the day we almost lost
american democracy which by the way this
country is not uh dave by the way has a
solo show this friday before our show in
colorado springs grand junction colorado
mesa theater all right we actually have
some uh we had a little bit of a dust up
here
uh in our in our studio this last week
uh with so we're actually going to need
to clear something up with gingersnap
and uh and and gunderson uh on mug club
youtube you don't want to see this you
don't wanna you don't know about this
piss off
foreign